we end this lecture sequence with the
most important property of expectations
namely linearity the idea is pretty
simple suppose that our random variable
X is the salary of a random person out
of some population so that we can think
of the expected value of X as the
average salary within that population
and now suppose that everyone gets a
raise and Y is the new salary and
generously the new salary is twice the
old salary plus a bonus of $100 what
happens to the expected value of the
salary or the average salary well the
new average salary which is the expected
value of 2x plus 100 is twice the old
average plus a hundred so doubling
everyone's salary and giving to everyone
an additional hundred what it does to
the average is that it doubles the
average and adds a hundred to it this is
the linearity property of expectation in
one particular example it's a most
intuitive property but it's worth also
deriving it in a formal way and the
derivation proceeds through the expected
value rule we're dealing here with a
particular function G which is a linear
function so we're dealing with a linear
function ax plus B and we're dealing
with the random variable Y which is G
applied to an original random variable X
so the expected value of y can be
calculated according to the expected
value rule it's the sum over all X's of
G of x times the probability of that
particular X and we plug in the space
cific form of the function G which is a
X plus B and then we separate the sum
into two sounds the first sum after
pulling out a constant of a takes this
form and the second sum after pulling
out the constant B takes this form now
the first song is a times the expected
value of x this is just the definition
of the expected value as for the second
sum we realize that this quantity is
equal to 1 because it is the sum of the
probabilities of all the different
values of X and this concludes the proof
of the linearity of expected values
notice that for expected values what we
have is that the expected value of y
which is expected value of G of X is the
same as G of the expected value of x the
expected value of a linear function is
the same linear function applied to the
expected value but this is an
exceptional case this does not happen in
general it's an exceptional function G
that makes this happen this property is
true for linear functions but for
nonlinear functions it is generally
false